[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous merci pour l'invitation
d'ailleurs je ne l'étais piste dpd pour
organiser cet événement je vais
commencer par en produire la musique
passion vous parlez de ce public y est
le clic désavantage est bien évidemment
impatient je faisais une petite
confidence aux jeunes là je leur disais
au fait que je savais pas ce que
j'allais dire en arrivant ici
tout ce que je savais c'est que j'avais
fait un mixte de photos qui pour moi
sont révélateurs de ces trois concepts
que je vais essayer de vous vous
présenter je vais introduire fait ce ted
en vous parlant de la passion ce que
c'est que la passion quelque chose qui
anime les gens tous les jours
régulièrement à chaque moment j'ai
commencé ce matin mon cours avec des
étudiants de bachelor 2 et ses étudiants
on a essayé d'échanger sur un événement
qui a marqué leur vie en termes de
changement un changement radical qui a
relancé leur façon de voir les choses
voir les choses différemment et dans
tout ce qu'ils ont exprimées ça a été
des expériences bien sûr principe
principalement personnel ils ont exprimé
la passion la passion des choses soute
repasser faire des choses qu'ils n'ont
pas l'habitude de faire quelque chose
qui permet de changer le futur changer
l'avenir changer leurs motivations
changer de direction comme dans une
entreprise changer son business model
qui arrive assez souvent d'ailleurs pour
steve jobs stang pouvait le voir au fait
les personnes avec des passions sont les
personnes qui sont capables de changer
le monde
et sans ces personnes là on est
incapable d'avancer
qu'est-ce qui a fait que starbucks et
starbucks actuellement qu'est-ce qui a
fait que apple et apple maintenant
qu'est-ce qui a fait que les restaurants
dans le noir sont les restaurants dans
le noir que tout le monde connaît ou pas
donc je vous laisserai et découvrir un
peu plus tard je vais faire une petite
introduction où vous définissant la
notion de passion là je reprends un peu
ma casquette de professeur
donc j'ai été chercher un peu au niveau
du dictionnaire larousse et j'essayais
de voir ce que c'était que la passion à
la première chose que je peux vous dire
que c'est que ça vient déjà du latin
du terme patio et bien évidemment
derrière ben c'est tout simplement dans
l'affect dans les émotions
généralement on parle d'un mouvement
affectif qu'on contrôle pas qui nous
submerge qui nous amène à des états
auxquels on s'attendait pas du tout vous
avez tous vécu la passion principalement
à la passion de l'amour
j'ai pas besoin de vous faire un je
dirais la us là dessus parce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous dépasse qui vous
dépasse dans vos démarches dans votre
façon de parler
vous pensez quelque chose vous faites
autre chose vous pensez avec votre
cerveau mais vous agissez avec votre cas
pour la plupart d'entre vous que
j'espère et c'est généralement quelque
chose que vous subissez qui vous tombe
dessus
un hobby une motivation un attrait pour
quelque chose pour quelqu'un pour une
action pour un mouvement pour une
association
peu importe vous serez dans cette
démarche et surtout votre principal
moteur ce sera cette passion donc ce que
j'essaie à chaque fois de mettre en
avant c'est ma passion
elle est où qu est ce que c est ce que
je suis capable de la chercher est ce
que je suis capable de la mener dans mon
quotidien qu'elle puisse me motive et
qu'elle puisse m'amener dans des
endroits des façons de penser des
projets auxquels j'ai jamais pensé
la passion pour moi c'est le quotidien
tous les matins quand vous vous levez
vous avez une passion qui vous anime qui
vous titille au plus profond de vous
même
ça peut être votre travail ça peut être
votre projet entrepreneurial
ça peut être votre copine ça va être
votre entourage familial
ça peut être plein de choses et ces
choses là c'est ce qui vous permette
d'exister
c'est ce qui vous permettent de vous
réveiller tous les matins êtes vous dire
que aujourd'hui je me lève parce que
j'ai une mission je dois assouvir ma
passion
la passion c'est plein de choses comme
vous pouvez le voir ici c'est quelque
chose de personnel
ça traite de l'expérience parce que
l'expérience amène aussi la passion ça
traite aussi des mots
ça traite aussi des actions se traitent
aussi de tout ce qui est le faire tout
ce qui est bien sûr le voyage vous
voyagez lorsque vous êtes dans la
passion la passion du travail
qu'est ce qui fait que la plupart des
individus vont tous les matins au boulot
et qu'ils sont contents d'y aller parce
qu'ils vont trouver un cadre de travail
agréable parce qu'ils vont trouver des
conditions de travail agréable parce
qu'ils ont des superviseurs qui sont
agréables
parce qu'ils ont des collègues agréable
et parce qu'ils aiment leur emploi la
pire chose qui peut vous arriver c'est
d'aller à votre travail
un pied devant et deep et derrière ça
veut dire que vous n'avez pas de passion
pour cet emploi et peut-être qu'à ce
moment là il faudra réfléchir et voir
les choses différemment
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous amener à
aller vers quelque chose d'utile d'utile
pour vous je reviens toujours à la même
chose c'est la passion mais est-ce que
la passion c'est quelque chose qui va
pertinemment vous animez tout le temps
bah je vais très honnête avec vous on
peut effectivement essayé de conjuguer
le sort essayer d'amener cette passion
essayez de l'animé de la titiller mais
c'est pas pour autant que vous l'aurez
vous pouvez passer toute votre vie sans
passer par cette étape qui vous changent
cette étape qui vous amène vers un état
autre que la normalité
le traditionnel et le classique et je
vais faire un petit détour pour vous
parler maintenant un peu plus de de
l'expérience professionnelle
en quoi la passion peut amener du
changement dans votre vie
professionnelle
comment elle peut animer votre quotidien
et surtout comment elle peut le changer
d'une façon radicale la seule expérience
jusqu'à maintenant qui m'a permis de
sentir cette passion c'est
l'entrepreneuriat l'entrepreneuriat
c'est une façon de voir les choses c'est
une vision qui vous est propre
c'est un ensemble de valeurs c'est votre
histoire
c'est votre vécu c'est les relations que
vous aurez avec vos collaborateurs vous
allez créer de la valeur économique et
social économique parce que vous allez
créer du cash et social parce que vous
créez déjà de l'emploi
de l'emploi c'est important donner du
bonheur aux gens leur donner de la
passion un motif pour se lever tous les
matins un revenu vous êtes là parce que
vous allez créer un projet qui peut être
social ou pas peu importe mais dans tous
les cas vous avez créé quelque chose et
ce sentiment de création ce sentiment
lorsque vous êtes dans votre bureau et
que vous voyez arriver des salariés des
collaborateurs il est indescriptible
c'est une aventure l'entrepreneuriat
c'est une aventure qui est unique
alors que vous soyez averses au risque
ou pas c'est pas la question
la question c'est pourquoi vous voulez
tenter l'expérience entrepreneuriale est
ce que c'est parce que tout simplement
vous avez une opportunité de business
que vous avez détecté ou parce que tout
simplement vous êtes obligés de créer
vous savez il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui créent parce qu'ils sont obligés de
créer leur propre emploi
et là je suis pas sûr que la passion
c'est quelque chose qui les anime
je parle bien du niveau professionnel
mais attention lorsqu'on regarde
exemptes et dans le processus de
création
on s'aperçoit que même s'il est obligé
de créer son propre emploi via
l'entrepreneuriat via la création d'une
entité
c'est parce qu'il est animé par la
passion de ses enfants de sa femme de
son cadre familial qu'il a même qui le
pousse qui lui donne de la motivation à
faire des choses qui n'a pas envie
c'est ça la passion aussi c'est une
autre forme de passion que vous devez
voir que vous devez ressentir au plus
profond de vous même et c'est ce qui
amène cette question ben passion et
entrepreneuriat est ce que c'est quelque
chose de compatibles la réponse est bien
évidemment oui pourquoi je vous parle de
passion aussi d'entrepreneuriat parce
qu'à un moment donné vous savez comme
chez spiderman la passion amène à la
dérive
vous savez la passion c'est pas toujours
quelque chose de gai c'est pas toujours
l'amour c'est pas toujours quelque chose
de plaisant
la passion c'est aussi la souffrance une
souffrance que personne ne peut
comprendre à part vous et cette
souffrance
peu d les lieux un processus particulier
qui vous permet de passer d'un
entrepreneur passionné intéressant
reconnu par tout le monde
collectif collégial dans sa prise de
décision et ainsi de suite à ce qu'on
appelle le dark side of entrepreneurs le
dark side c'est quoi passer spiderman
temps effectivement il s'est transformé
en spiderman mais en noir et le dark
side of est il est animé par quoi au
final il est animé par le côté obscur de
la passion le côté obscur de la passion
c'est ce qui anime certaines personnes
me dites pas que vous n'avez jamais
rencontré d'entrepreneurs individualiste
qui ne pense qu'à lui qui ne pensent à
évidemment chaos salaire qui peut tirer
de son entreprise il ne pense que en
termes d' opportunisme exagéré poussé à
outrance
il existe ces entrepreneurs là et tant
mieux parce que cet art semble là qui va
créer un équilibre au sein du marché
il faut des bons entrepreneurs et des
mauvais entrepreneurs et c'est ce qui
nous permet d'avancer
et heureusement d'ailleurs que ces
entrepreneurs là qu'ils sont pas du tout
dans le spectre classiques existent
parce que c'est ce qui nous permet de
valoriser valorisé par dont les autres
personnes qu'on qualifie de héros il y à
des héros en entrepreneuriat des
personnes qui sortent du commun
il ya des personnes auxquelles on ne
confierait pas 5 euros 10 euros
parce que vous dans votre perception
vous pensez que ces personnes là ne sont
pas légitimes pour emmener des
entreprises pour créer de l'emploi et
bien évidemment pour créer de la valeur
bah détrompez vous il existe des héros
des héros unique des publics qu'on
qualifie d' des avantages et des publics
qui n'ont pas la même je dirais
perception des choses qu'on ne voit pas
perçoit pas de la même manière parce
qu'ils sont différents ils sont
différents parce qu'ils sont différents
physiquement parce qu'ils sont jeunes
veulent et orange et bleu parce que tout
simplement ils sont plus
euh parce que tout simplement ils
viennent pas du même endroit que vous et
moi ils sont différents mais qui est
différent au final est-ce que c'est eux
est-ce que c'est nous c'est simple il
existe ce qu'on appelle ces fameux
publiques des avantages et en
entrepreneuriat qui créent de la valeur
et pour moi en fait il ya trois
personnes qui à chaque fois que j'ai
envie de parler de ce genre de public la
de cette passion d'entreprendre le goût
du risque et tous les problématiques
toutes les problématiques qu'ils ont
effectivement été obligé de braver bain
tout d'abord je présente didier roche
didier roche c'est un grand monsieur
j'aime pas parler du terme en deep run
arias mais c'est une personne atteinte
d'un handicap cécité qui a créé son
entreprise
mais avant de créer son entreprise il
faut savoir que le fait d'être
malheureusement et c'est la vie c'est
comme ça atteint d'un handicap fait qu'
il n'est pas perçu de la même manière
par tout le monde
par exemple didier roche quand il est
parti pour ouvrir son compte bancaire
bin un conseiller clientèle
professionnelle d'une banque qu'on
nommera pas via dit mais comment vous
voulez gérer une entreprise alors que
vous voyez rien six mois après didier
roche créé les restaurants dans le noir
didier roche créer les spas dans noir
didier roche créé le groupe éthique
connexion et plus il pèse maintenant
plusieurs centaines voire plusieurs
millions d'euros
c'est une success story qui vous
démontre que la passion peut dépasser
tous les obstacles auxquels vous pouvez
faire face deuxième entrepreneurs gilles
bouchard gilles bouchard c'est quelqu'un
qui vient d'origine d'afrique du sud qui
a occupé des postes
je dirais c'est important je crois qu'il
a dépassé 55 60 ans c'est un saignant
j'ai pas si vous savez en france les
seniors sont les personnes selon l'insee
qui ont dépassé 45 ans j'y suis pas
encore mais
y est presque eh ben gilles bouchard
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il s'est
intéressé aux seniors et il s'est dit
que les seniors c'est un vrai vivier
d'expériences d'expertisés de capital
social ce sont des personnes atypiques
singulière c'est une vraie mine d'or en
termes de connaissances et de
savoir-faire
comment faire en sorte pour les amener à
être utile
comment faire en sorte pour braver par
exemple anxiété face à la mort qui les
anime tous les jours parce que vous
savez un senior plus on augmente dans
l'âge peut effectivement cette sensation
de la fin arrive
comment faire en sorte pour valoriser
par exemple le concept de postérité avec
eux les seniors cherche toujours a
effectivement laissé quelque chose de
leur passage à leurs enfants petits
enfants
une trace d'eux comment faire pour que
ces personnes-là transmettent aussi les
connaissances qu'ils détiennent
bah c'est simple le plus simple c'est
l'entrepreneuriat et bats la passion de
gilles bouchard un ancien de harvard
quand même à fonder l'exécutif business
accélérateur dédié principalement aux
seniors et aux équipes inter
générationnelle ça veut dire quoi les
équipes intergénérationnel ça veut dire
tout simplement les équipes qui sont
créées par d'un côté des jeunes et de
l'autre côté enseignants ayez un mixte
de compétences de connaissances de
capital social économique et autres qui
amène font forcément de la performance
la troisième personne
c'est un immigré qui est arrivé dans les
années 70 qui vient d'être élu
entrepreneur de l'année et par hasard
buy vient de série
quand il est arrivé il s'est même pas et
il connaît même pas sa date de naissance
il a repris une entreprise
ingénieur de formation un doctorat en
poche la passion l'a amené à créer une
entreprise à la reprendre et d'en faire
un ou une des meilleures success story
en france
eh ben
c'est un exemple pour tous que ce soit
monsieur altrad que ce soit gilles
bouchard que ce soit didier roche
ce sont des personnes qui nous
expliquent tous les jours qu'il faut
croire en nous il faut croire dans notre
passion et que l'entrepreneuriat c'est
avant tout de la passion c'est de la
passion mélangé à de la raison c'est un
ensemble d'actions alors on peut vous
dire tout ce qu'on peut ce qu'on veut il
n'y a pas d'argent et pas de capital on
peut pas vous aidez votre projet bidons
etc
mais il faut croire en vous il faut
croire en vous parce que c'est là dessus
que je vais conclure rien n'est
impossible
rien n'est impossible
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et